[Music]
all right we're starting 2021
off with some cheese man whoo cheese man
gossip oh so the tea
so have you guys heard about kim and
kanye divorce
yes i saw this meme where they were
passing around a basketball and they're
like that's the nba players passing
around kim kardashian you see that that
was hilarious
but i mean who's really she's winning
she's getting all this
fresh new dick right i mean actually i
read something
from a source of hers that they're
saying like
nah kim is not gonna be dating if it is
she is gonna date it's for career
opportunities and she's already one of
the most famous person
like people in the world she doesn't
need to get more famous so and also she
doesn't know how to date
privately so she's like not even trying
to do that you don't need to become a
lawyer
you know this is a plot line dude
they're so next level
i mean i don't hold anything past you do
you think to to so next level
to do it it's like divorce and then they
get back together oh my god what a great
story
because when when she got married to
who's the basketball player
chris humphrey or something yeah like
that was the most lucrative wedding in
history she got a bunch of brand news
for like a day or tv yeah they married
for like two days so like i don't i
wouldn't put it past them to not make it
just the plot well they like to
stay on the google trends page and so if
they're slipping
somehow like they [ __ ] covered they
need a big plot line
yeah they're battling cult like they're
against covet and trump that's a pretty
hard yeah
like them together though because
they're both just like weird eccentric
people they belong yeah who else would
they if they are really splitting though
i can also see why that would happen
because i feel like
they're both highly ambitious but i
think in different directions and it
takes
like twice as much work if you guys
aren't ambitious in the same direction i
i feel like kim is bigger than kanye and
she's
outgrowing him and she wants to go
higher so she's gonna
now get with trump oh [ __ ]
well for her she said the last straw or
according to
the source is that her last draw was
when kanye ran for president
and and then she they also said like if
you notice kim
never once endorsed him publicly i know
she never tweeted
she never tweeted about the birthday
party one time yeah i know and so
uh they were saying like her silence
spoke volumes right like
she's obviously she's probably like you
idiot
yeah and then so all this she's like i
want to be president why are you running
still in my dreams oh yeah who knows
but uh but yeah so they're saying that
they
have been in talks about divorcing for
the past year
and kim convinced kanye to go live in
wyoming in their ranch that they have in
wyoming so this past year like
they've been separated so they can
quietly get this divorce
settled that's their version of sleeping
on the couch you don't sleep on that
couch in the ranch in wyoming
dude have you seen these like wyoming
real estate videos
okay so there are wyoming ranch videos
specifically made
for like millionaires and billionaires
right and
they do this crazy ass presentation with
like
drone footage and all that you can
better the hills you can see like the
[ __ ] buffalo running and all this
yeah and then they show you like 3
000 acres or some outrageous amount
right you have your own
river you have your own lake you have an
airstrip you have like
five big ass mansions that are like
cabin mansions it's like glamping to the
next level
and you have like a whole bunch of their
homes
they're glamping yeah it's not their
main home it's wyoming though so it's
kind of silly
there's nothing there and then so you
just have staff there that's like
just working and taking care of your
horses or whatever
but i was like this is that next level
of wealth
where i can just live through the video
and go yeah i'm gonna buy this through
the video
wow that shit's crazy yeah when you
first said that i was like wyoming ranch
i think that's
maybe four thousand airs i feel like
yeah pretty affordable
yeah yeah oh actually isn't jacksonville
wyoming where like some of the
wealthiest people in the world live
really yeah yeah i don't know i don't
know we're just trying to [ __ ] on
wyoming oh sorry i remember
talking to a dude who was from a really
wealthy family who was talking about how
like there was this one city in wyoming
i think it was jacksonville but i don't
know
yeah my brother went to a mechanic
school in wyoming and then with my
parents
and i did a road trip when i was a kid
they said that the gas station people
were so surprised that we spoke english
they brought out the whole village to
come meet us
stop yeah did you meet the village
did you take pictures well it was just
like people that lived
around the gas station or something they
were just come on over here and talk to
this kid he speaks english how did he
learn
english i was picturing like a star wars
movie where everyone's like around you
and like like the ewok village or
something yeah i don't remember i was
too young
but then my parents told me they give
you fruits
say say some words kid you know do you
not use a fork
yeah i don't know damn that's crazy
that's how rural
it is yeah they they they've never seen
an agent
they never seen an asian they never seen
one that speaks english
wow you blew their minds you know [ __ ]
with them like oh i put a spell on you
i know huh i don't know how old i was
though i don't even remember
yeah but yeah so this whole kim and
kanye thing it's so
it's it's sparking a lot of other really
crazy
rumor like there's this one that i'm
like how the [ __ ] do people come up with
this
yes but apparently the reason why
kim and kanye are getting a divorce is
because kim
caught kanye cheating on her with
jeffree star what wait kanye was [ __ ]
with jeffree star
writers are going crazy they're good
yeah this is a rumor so jeffree star a
male
beauty guru who has like 17 million
followers or something
he and also by the way he's he's very
controversial himself he's constantly in
a lot of drama youtube drama yeah
youtube drama
so uh the reason why this rumor started
is because this other
very problematic person named eva louise
she she started this rumor and on her
tick tock and this is what she said
now that kim's finally doing this i feel
like i can spill the tea that i've been
holding on to
for months this whole divorce comes as
no surprise connie has been hooking up
with a very famous beauty guru
male beauty guru a lot of people in the
scene have known for a while
so she posted on her tick tock and in
the comments she was
liking comments that were asking like is
it jeffree star so she was confirming
so how did this even happen were they
like at a house party and then someone
opened the door and they were doing a l7
and it's like what the [ __ ] and then
they close the door they're like oh my
god you wouldn't see
you didn't realize what i just saw l7
yeah yeah oh yeah what is that 69 okay
okay
it's an l7 um you know what's funny
about
kanye though is i can see kanye on a
podcast or something somewhere being
like
like i have been i was only conditioned
to think i wouldn't like having sex with
jeffree star
oh for sure man i can he's so out of
this world yeah i'm like
what it's like though when you get to
that level normal [ __ ]
doesn't turn you on anymore because i
mean he can have so many groupies right
of like everything every single booty
dancer
ever so then now he wants something
different like let me get something new
well the way people are connecting the
dots here is because jeffrey
and kanye apparently live in the same
community here
in l.a calabasas yeah and
and also recently jeffrey starr
mentioned that he's moving to wyoming
and so that'll do it connection there
but do you think it's love or do you
think it's lust
i was just hoping you know like it's
kind of like maybe
maybe you know connie was walking out to
grab the
newspaper newspaper yeah or take out the
trash they don't do newspapers anymore
maybe yeah and they both were taken out
the trash and they
and connie looks over and he's all like
man something about that girl across the
street makes me feel a certain way
and then he's like oh wait that's
jeffree star
this whole time right and he's like well
maybe i gotta check my sexuality this
this minute and then they start talking
and then this like
sparks fly and then they fall in love
and he's like this whole time i thought
i loved
kim kardashian but in reality i like how
he calls his own wife kim kardashian
person last name yeah my friend kim west
it sounds both really like romantic and
like a geico commercial
yeah i know right and like a south park
episode yeah yeah yeah
and then like yeah they have that moment
where like they
they're like walking the dogs or
something and then they meet and then
like oh and the dogs like tangle them up
and then there's a spaghetti bowl out of
nowhere and they share a noodle and they
kiss well they're hungry
and it bothered our dog's [ __ ] and then
when they go to pick it up
at the same time their hands get
together like with the [ __ ] on it with
the [ __ ]
are they picking up dog [ __ ] no no no no
assistant for sure is doing no they
bought assistance
no and then so they're also saying that
like all like
more dots being connected here is back
in 2009 jeffrey starr
in his song [ __ ] please he rhymed about
having sex with kanye
and but he also did that with a number
of other a-list celebrities and then he
also
in early what was it everyone has a
bucket list
yeah and in 2011 he replied to kanye
saying last
night was so fun xoxo and
but around that time he used to
frequently tweet a lot of a-list
celebrities too
so it's not really credible yeah who
knows who he really sucked yeah who
knows but
so jeffrey he's always saying like oh
yeah i'm [ __ ] some like really famous
people right now
and and he's always like starting
stirring up drama
and always claiming to be [ __ ]
someone really really famous
so who knows yeah everyone's got their
own story lines for staying trending and
then i love
seeing them converge like he's always
like i'm [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] [ __ ] and
connie is like i'm a genius i'm a genius
i want to see the worlds collide though
yeah like right now they're kind of
in the same crazy eccentric
entertainment world but i want to see it
going into like
the food world oh gordon ramsay jeffree
star
i was picturing an l7 yeah at l7 and l7
world
yeah let's let's let's see somebody else
let's mix it up maybe
a different genre yeah um what are the
ones that matter though that are like
fun or it might be funny i don't know i
got a brainstormer
we're workshopping it everyone yeah yeah
like like like let's say um
tim allen and boris johnson no that's
too old school that's
nice he's like these references are
getting really crazy
i think my dad would get that yeah yeah
yeah it's two it's too old abortion
dr quinn medicine woman
and abigail from the crucible
[Music]
foreign